well Facebook's entire business model is
built on harvesting your personal
information and yet somehow blue check
Twitter just learned this today and
freaked out when they found out
Cambridge analytic a UK data firm hired
by the Trump campaign is mired in a
scandal after a whistleblower claims the
company misled Facebook users in order
to collect their personal data well that
sounds very spooky and what's kind of
spooky actually but weirdly it wasn't
that spooky six years ago in 2012 the
Obama administration found itself being
congratulated by the media for how it
gathered Facebook data in order to
marshal votes when Obama advisor says
Facebook let them break the company's
rules because quote they were on our
side
Beverley Hallberg is president of
District Media Group and she joins us
ain't so Beverly thanks for coming on
the the core story here is shocking or
no not as shocking as liberals want it
to sound so we really have liberals
going after this story saying there's
something here this is the Trump
campaign who figured out a way to mine
data that they shouldn't have but what
the Trump campaign did is exactly what
the Obama campaign did what the Hillary
campaign did what this is really about
is Facebook who was the poor actor this
was all be talk before 2014 were
Facebook with the privacy policy we all
sign up on where we say sure you can
have my data that is all legal but what
they did at that point is they not only
said to a third party hey with this app
you can have the person's data who agree
to it but they also took the data of
their friends that is where the issue is
it's the privacy not just a view but
also the privacy of those that you're
connected with that is the heart of this
issue what we find from campaigns
they're just using data that's out there
and when you even think about campaigns
these days people are on social media
this is where you need to have campaign
ads so it's not a data issue as far as
the campaign's go
it's what Facebook did at that point in
time when it comes to their privacy so
Facebook also collects all kinds of data
that you're not aware that it's
collecting for example when you visit a
store Facebook knows that Facebook can
make assumptions about your net worth
about your personal life and it sells
those data to companies correct
we willingly give it whether it's a
Fitbit that you're putting in for me
right man I use ways to navigate traffic
I think about that and whether or not
what is going to be used with that data
so we willingly given and I actually
think especially when it comes to
parents when you have children who are
giving their information to apps giving
information to Facebook and other social
media platforms you have to realize all
of that is available to companies to
sell I think where this comes down to is
the free market solving it you already
had a movement called delete Facebook I
think that's why Mark Zuckerberg even
came out today on five days after this
scandal to talk about what really took
place because I think the free market is
gonna solve this their stock dropped
fifty billion dollars I think the free
market is gonna say hey I'm not gonna
use your platform if you're gonna be
selling my privacy in this way
finally liberals are waking up to it but
I mean more as a political matter so
morning Joe has spent the last year and
a half trying to figure out how Trump
got elected yeah and figure out there
must have been something nefarious it
couldn't have nothing to do with the
idea that his ideas were popular with
Americans like that's not even on the
table do you think Cambridge analytical
will be a satisfactory answer for them
are they going to say you know this is
how it happened it won't be a true
satisfactory answer but I think they may
want to use it I mean Hillary Clinton is
still on the tour trying to figure out
what happened well here's the thing this
is not your answer either but this is
what liberals are trying to do to try to
prove he is not the actual candidate the
impeach Trump camp is still moving on
this but this is really nothing because
Facebook already changed their policies
Facebook is bad apart and aside from
campaign okay fair enough
Beverly's great to see you thank you